As you might have noticed, the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is big and getting bigger these days.
However, the sheer level of talent that's
involved in bringing all those superheroes
and villains on screens both big and small
is even bigger.
The list of Academy Award winners who have
either appeared in a MCU movie or that are
set to do so in the near future is currently
comprised of no less than 26 actors, according
to IGN.
That number should give you a rough idea about
the overall caliber of talent behind the many
Marvel characters to grace the silver screen.
Of course, there are still plenty of great
actors who haven't joined the MCU in any capacity
yet, and fans are often speculating about
the next big-name addition to the sprawling
mega-franchise.
He might not have an Oscar to his name yet,
but Keanu Reeves is one of the biggest names
who tend to come up in such conversations.
He's easily one of the biggest action movie
actors who has yet to attach their names to
a Marvel Studios project, which seems all
the more glaring when you remember that his
two most famous roles — Neo in "The Matrix"
movies and the titular character of the "John
Wick" franchise — are essentially superheroes
themselves.
"He was the one you sent to kill the f---ing
Boogeyman."
Reeves and the MCU seem like a perfect fit,
but is there any chance for this match made
in tentpole movie heaven to ever happen?
Now, the actor has finally weighed in on whether
he'd ever join the Marvel Cinematic universe
in a video interview with Esquire.
While fielding questions about roles from
throughout his career, Reeves had a surprisingly
straightforward answer in response to Esquire
asking him outright whether or not a Marvel
film role might be in his future.
First of all, Reeves noted that the word "universe"
is starting to fail to adequately account
for the true scope of the MCU, saying,
"Isn't it bigger than a universe?
It's almost like a Multiverse.
It's a Marvel-verse."
However, he ultimately didn't dodge the question
about becoming a part of that world himself,
saying,
"It would be an honor."
He then spoke to the quality of talent involved
behind the scenes of many of Marvel's flagship
projects, saying,
"There's some really amazing directors and
visionaries, and they're doing something that
no one's really ever done.
It's special in that sense, in terms of the
scale, the ambition, the production.
So it would be cool to be a part of that."
All in all, it appears that Reeves is, at
the very least, not yet a part of an MCU project
— or if he is, he's clearly not at liberty
to share the news with the public yet.
Nevertheless, he appears to be about as open
as an actor could be to the prospect of joining
Marvel's multibillion dollar franchise, meaning
that his eventual MCU debut remains a distinct,
enticing possibility.
"People keep asking me if I'm back, and I
haven't really had an answer.
But now, yeah, I'm thinking I'm back."
It's fascinating that Keanu Reeves actually
addressed the MCU rumors, and doubly so because
he didn't shoot them down.
After all, speculation of his involvement
in some upcoming MCU project has been running
rampant for years now.
Take the rumor that made the rounds in March
2020, for example.
It suggested that Reeves might become the
MCU incarnation of Ghost Rider.
The skull-faced, flaming motorcycle rider
might be an interesting choice, seeing as
a version of the character has already made
an appearance in the MCU-adjacent "Agents
of SHIELD," portrayed by Gabriel Luna — though
Reeves would probably portray the Johnny Blaze
version of the character, which was memorably
played by Nicolas Cage in the decidedly non-MCU
2007 movie "Ghost Rider," and its buckwild
sequel, "Ghost Rider: Spirit of Vengeance."
A recent Looper poll, meanwhile, determined
that fans want Reeves to portray the superhuman
Adam Warlock.
That role, of course, ultimately went to "Midsommar"
star Will Poulter, but there's plenty of reason
to assume that the rumor mill will keep turning
for quite a while.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movie rumors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.